a correr longas distâncias faz bem para
o coração a resposta dessa pergunta é
Depende a história da maratona data de
490 antes de Cristo a história da lenda
grega diz que Philips correu a planície
de maratona 42 km para chegar até apenas
e contar para os gregos a vitória contra
os persas porém após entregar essa
mensagem e sucumbiu morreu provavelmente
morreu do coração
e esses dados são importantes que em
2012 pesquisadores demonstraram que
maratonistas após a realização da prova
de 42km apresentavam ressonância
magnética do coração com dilatação das
câmaras cardíacas dilatação essa
diferente do habitual esses mesmos
pesquisadores conseguiram demonstrar em
provas de sangue que os pacientes
atletas que correram essa prova
apresentava níveis de enzimas do coração
similares a um infarto agudo do
miocárdio tão importante que em 2017
outros autores demonstraram que dezoito
por cento dos atletas que realizaram uma
prova de triathlon do sexo masculino
apresentavam cicatrizes dentro do
coração
a cicatriz essas que perduraram por até
seis meses após a realização da prova
e o número de pessoas que fazem prova de
rua que fazem maratonas estão em
constante crescimento atualmente e mesmo
assim nós não encontramos um aumento da
incidência de morte súbita de ataque
cardíaco de morte durante a realização
da prova porque
é porque eu treino de maratona exige
resiliência exige do indivíduo motivação
exige Foco
e a pessoa que treina para realizar uma
prova de maratona ela precisa adquirir
um hábito um hábito de realizar uma
atividade física regular esse hábito faz
com que eu diminua o meu risco
cardiovascular tanto que em 2020 alguns
pesquisadores conseguiram demonstrar que
para maratonistas estão treinando para
sua primeira maratona já tem benefício
de redução de 4 anos da idade das
artérias do seu coração esses mesmos
autores conseguiram demonstrar que você
treinar por uma maratona pelo hábito
pela motivação ter a resiliência de um
treinamento por uma prova de maratona
imuniza você de ter um infarto do
coração
e isso é tão relevante que e tão
pertinente as diretrizes nacionais e
internacionais que preconizam que para
prevenção de doença cardiovascular eu
tenho que adotar um hábito de atividade
física regular hábito esse de correr 75
minutos três vezes por semana hábito
esse de caminhar 150 minutos por semana
somente de realizar qualquer uma dessas
atividades reduza o risco em trinta por
cento e você sofrer um infarto do
coração
por isso é tão importante porque você
diminui os fatores de riscos associados
ao infarto a doença cardiovascular ao
AVC praticar uma atividade física
regular faz com que você reduza
cinquenta por cento o seu nível de
colesterol sanguíneo
e faz com que você reduza de 5 a 7 MM de
mercúrio da sua pressão arterial
e reduz os níveis no sangue de Açúcar
e diminui a resistência à insulina o
principal fator associado ao diabetes
tipo 2 treinar por uma prova fazer uma
uma atividade física regular faz com que
você diminua a sua preferência abdominal
diminui a obesidade
bom então corra
é a vida de um coração
e é uma corrida então corra mas não
corra muito não corra muito rápido
aproveite o treinamento Aproveite a
jornada não se importe com final não se
importe com os 42 195 Muito obrigado e